demandez moi de combattre le diable
d'aller défier les dragons du néant
de vous construire des tours des
cathédrales
simplement
[Applaudissements]
demandez moi de briser les montagnes
tu as les plonger dans laquelle des
volcans
tout me paraît
réalisable
et pour
tant quand je
la regarde moi l'homme loup au cœur
d'acier
devant son corps de femme je suis un
géant de papier
quand je la caresse et que j'ai peur
tous les veillées
et ma tendresse je suis un géant de
papier
[Musique]
demandez moi de réduire en poussière
cette planète ou un dieu se perd
elle est pour moi comme une fourmilière
ton écrase du pied demandez-moi
[Musique]
et d'arrêter ce soir le cours du temps
tout me paraît
réalisable
et pourtant
quand je la regarde
moi l'homme lourd carnassier
devant son corps de femme je suis un
géant de papier
et que j'ai peur de l'éveiller
de tout
ma tendresse je suis un géant de papier
[Musique]
quand je la regarde moi l'homme
au cœur d'acier
devant son corps de femme je suis un
géant de papier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]